Next up, let's go over the primary nodes and textures you'll be using in your projects.
So we'll talk about the primary PBR inputs here, the base color or Albedo maps, metallic
roughness and specular, and also talk about the textures, what Unreal supports and what
the kind of best workflow is for using textures inside of Unreal.
We'll talk about texture pyramids or MIP maps as they're referred to, and then import in
your textures how to get your content into Unreal.
So the primary PBR inputs are the base color, and we'll go through creating a material
at the end, so you don't need to worry specifically if you're unfamiliar with this interface,
but essentially we've got a base color going in, which is just this blue color, and then
we can set some metallic specular or roughness values depending on how we want this material
to look.
So this is all handled on the editor side.
So the base color or Albedo map, as we refer to it, is a flat color without specularity
or shading.
So roughness is key to define the look of a material, and it's selling the real world
equivalent.
So the Albedo map is a linear RGB, which is a vector 3, which is actually what we saw
in that previous slide.
So this is a vector 3, so it has three numerical values.
So that's a vector 3 going in there, and the values between 0 and 1.
So we want to avoid any pure black in Albedo, and we want to avoid any pure white, as they
don't really exist in nature.
So to get the metallic feel, essentially metallic is a grayscale value that ranges from 0 to
1, and really it's either 1 or 0.
It's either on or off.
You don't really use any mid-grounds here, but when on, which is number 1, it yields
100% specular reflection.
So you can see the sliding scale of 0 to 1 there, 1 being the most specular and 0 being
the most absorbent of the reflection.
And then the roughness map is a grayscale value again that ranges from 0 to 1, but the
ranges from smooth is like a mirror-like surface, which is 0, which you can see on the left
here, to a rougher matte surface, which is on the right side there.
So unlike with metallic, this really can be dialed into whatever value you'd like.
As long as that value is between 0 and 1, you can say 0.35, for example, and really
dial in that roughness for whatever you're trying to achieve there.
So specular then is a grayscale value that ranges from 0 to 1, and it's a good rule of
thumb is to set the specular value to 0.5 and fine-tune it from the roughness value
instead.
Have it on by default and set it to 0.5 so no node connection is needed for it.
And in some cases, you may decide to edit the roughness value or use a bitmap to that
effect.
So you can achieve this by using stylized looks over the top of glossiness.
It's not always needed when using a roughness value, but it's worth considering the specularity
in balance with the other inputs of your material there.
And so Unreal Engine supported formats.
In an uncompressed file format, Unreal does support BMPs, Targets, PSDs.
It's worth noting that depending on the export of the Targets, if you're setting a 32-bit
there, you can get an alpha out of that Targets.
And then compressed versions, you can have a PNG, JPEG, DDS, and HDR.
For optimization purposes, it's best to work with PNG due to its lightweight file size
and the ability to have transparency info when needed.
But it's worth considering the different formats depending on the project's requirements there.
And so when looking at guidelines, textures should always be a power of 2.
So when we import our textures, maybe it's 16 by 16 or 8192 by 8192, and any variation,
you know, 64 by 64, et cetera.
But the textures don't have to be square.
It's mainly that they're a power of 2 that's the important point.
So if you wanted 16 by 128, that's fine.
So they're all acceptable examples as long as they're power of 2.
And textures can affect the streaming and memory management.
So it's important to keep this in mind, especially on that previous slide where we were talking
about the different file formats.
Making sure you're considering the memory management of what the project's output is.
That's super useful, especially at the start of the project when trying to define your
pipeline there.
And high frequency textures can cause anti-aliasing and artifacts.
So a couple of examples of the different import settings used for maybe streamed or non-streamed
textures and also how to scale the number of mipmaps, for example.
So whether you have alpha channels or not, the size of the textures, the method that
they're imported at, they can all be dialed in for the project's requirements essentially.
And on the texture pyramid side, which is the mipmaps, mipmaps are another custom setting.
So we can set these, when you use the textures inside the material editor, you can see that
you can set these values on the material editor in the expression sample.
And then you can also double click any textures and set the texture group from here as well.
So useful to keep in mind when working with texture pyramids.
And then when you're importing your textures, so you can see from the previous slide, we
have this drop down here.
That's what we're referring to on the mipmap side.
But then also when we import the textures, you can either use the import button in the
content browser or you can go to file, import, or you can simply just drag and drop the file
from the Windows Explorer into the content browser and that will import it just fine.
All textures are converted to UAssets.
So when we're looking at Unreal file formats, even if it was a PNG that you're importing,
the PNG then gets turned into a UAsset on the import.
You can open a texture using this texture editor that you can see on the right hand
side here with a double click of that texture that you've just imported.
And so here we can change any compression settings, anything we need to.
There's a lot of just scalability optionality here that you can dial in for your relevant
projects and you can even import at higher resolution and downscale it inside the engine
if you need to.
So we can also enable or disable linear color space here, which is the sRGB as well.
So all these things hopefully useful to keep in mind when starting your projects.